hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast lab of the future the
considerations for entering the data
lab space i'm susie valdez of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by
lab roots and sponsored by even door for
more information on our sponsor
visit them at evandorp.com before we
begin
i'd like to encourage you to engage with
us you can submit
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
simply type them into the ask a question
box on the left
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation i would now like to
turn the presentation over to our
speaker
steven day operational marketing team
leader northern europe at eppendorf uk
limited welcome steven you may now begin
your presentation
hello everyone um thank you very much
for joining me today um
as i said my name's steve i work in
marketing at eppendorf
and today what i want to do is have a
little bit of a look
at some of the challenges you see in the
lab how digitization
now and in the future can help you
reduce
or even remove these challenges and then
what you need to consider when you're
taking your first steps into a digital
lab
so before we start i want to have a
little bit of look at
where we are right now so is it the
digital future
or is it actually already today
it's interesting many of us are already
in a digital world
they're already integrated into
connected devices to internet of things
if you consider your personal life um
you are potentially using an ai
on your phone regularly you may have a
digital assistant in your home
which you use for managing your heating
or your lights
something like an amazon echo or a
google home
many of us already use cloud-based
computing
and we trust it with our most personal
data our banking information
our health care information pensions
details
so we're already very integrated in our
personal life
now if you offset that against
potentially your
life in the lab how many people relate
to this
a paper lab book potentially with
printouts of digital information stuck
in a truly analog
way of storing data and how many people
can relate to potentially
inventory management not organized
we have no idea what's at the back of
the freezer no one's been to the back of
that freezer for
five ten years anything could be there
if you have put some kind of
uh data management system into your
laboratory
potentially it's just based around excel
excel whilst true it is a step into the
digital
it's very hard to manage who's had
access
what changes were made version of
control um
so it has a lot of the challenges that
you'd have with with
a non-digital system
so before we start i wanted to ask a
question now there's many elements for
digitization
and many benefits you can gain however i
want to ask one question to sort of
start you thinking about how
digitization can support you
do you worry about what the impact of
losing data will be for you when you're
laboratory in your organization
i mean clearly there's a huge
implication of the time
you've spent a lot of time doing the
experiments generating that data
there's a cost associated with that of
course
you run an experiment as a cost of
reagents it's also the cost of your time
now these things combine it doesn't
matter if you're a
government lab or a
academic lab or a commercial lab this is
still
intellectual property this is still the
output the value that comes out of your
laboratory
what kind of impact you have if you lose
either the
supporting data or the actual data
that builds your intellectual properties
i just want to put that question there
to start you thinking about
how digitization can directly impact the
output of your lab
we wanted to have a look at the
challenges
that we see either currently or
potentially emerging
into uh that work as time goes on
and really look at some of the pain
points and and
considerations you'll have as you start
to think about how we'll work in the
future
as equipment becomes well there's two
trends for equipment
at the moment one is where equipment
becomes almost more disposable
and commoditized however i might argue
that that is a trend that will probably
finish as
as environmental concerns become more
important
the other trend is that equipment is
becoming more and more
complex and it's servicing me to
becoming more and more complex
when you get pieces of equipment which
are central to our to how laboratory
runs
and needs a lot of uptime the servicing
requirements for bidding equipment
are becoming more and more
as time goes on there's either uh
there could be reduction in funds or a
reduction in people
so these are the two main resources that
that you have in your laboratory
it could also be um that you're expected
to output more with your current
resources
and this is going to lead to a much
greater need of efficiency
how can we get more out of what we have
currently
with some of the trends in science now
we've seen
an increase over the years in sample
density it could be
population genetics or personalized
medicines something which leads to a
much
larger number of samples coming to your
laboratory now more samples
means more information to manage
more chiefs to identify how do you
manage that in your laboratory
environment
and this inherently means those larger
data sets
how do you manage data sets with
different sources
structured data in tables and
unstructured data like images how do you
create an information management system
that allows you to pull this information
together
and gain insight there is going to be
whilst storage is cheap then managing
that storage becomes a more
complex question as we get creating
greater data sets to to manage
and uh and and work with in our daily
life
security and integrity people associate
security data security heavily with
digital data
but actually it's an inherent issue with
analog data as well
if you have a pile of lab books in the
corner of your laboratory
how do you manage that data how do you
manage security of that data
how do you ensure that data is backed up
and can be found elsewhere
how do you ensure you can search that
data
data securities is as important for
analog
data as it is for digital data the
difference being
analog data is much harder to track
who's had access to backup
and if damage were to occur so integrity
to be able to read and to be able to
utilize that data
how do you make sure you can do that in
an analog system
i think current times have shown there's
very much a need
to be able to support an agile workforce
one that isn't always
in its place at work um where you maybe
don't have access to your laboratory
or don't have access to your to your
office space and therefore maybe not
have access to all of your
your data in your experiments um
there's also the the trend of people
expecting a more blurred relationship
between their work life
um their that their work and their lives
their work lives in their personal lives
being able to
to really blend those two parts which
requires the ability to to work remotely
and work at different times so how can
you support
a more agile workforce
many lab situations it's clear that
greater traceability and more proof
is required so being able to track
samples
effectively as you have greater sample
density
how do you make sure you're able to find
that specific example
how can you see who's had access to a
freezer
how do you see who started a program as
time goes on and we need to have
a greater burden of proof associated
with what we're creating
and the science that we're performing
how do we do that
and then more important how do we
document and validate this
so these are some of the challenges that
we see moving into into the future and
you can pretty much group these into
into three areas one is there will be a
need to reduce
costs um be that through people
um not be able to increase people by
making people more efficient and what
they can do
or by reducing funds or
simply the need to do more
there's a need to save time and that's
very closely linked
to um to reducing cost of course
if you need to be more efficient and you
have less people then you need to save
time
and of course there's a reduction in
risk which again is heavily tied to this
how can we reduce the risk to our work
be that repeating experiments
or having work that we can't prove and
validate at the end
so what we wanted to do to illustrate
this process
was really to start talking about taking
a very simple
um sample processing
and have a look at it and see how
digitization can impact from different
places
so before we started we just wanted to
look at the different elements that you
might need to consider
so the first question is
is the storage location where is my
sample
and can you prove where your example is
next question is sample identification
what or potentially who is my sample
from
what has happened to my sample and when
did that happen
to myself
can i approve all of this can i easily
create a documented um
process which i can show what has
happened to my sample
and this is a total digital sample
management process
where we can show who or what
when and where a sample is at any one
time
so what we wanted to do now is have a
look at the different
places where digitization could have an
impact or
potentially an analog system or a
non-connected digital system
would create challenges and additional
work
so we picked something topical an rna
prep from a patient sample
as it seems to be quite quite topical
right now
so we start off with a collection of the
of patient samples
which is clearly something that we need
to do in this process you may get the
data um
electronically in a in a spreadsheet
you'll get it the sample in some form of
vessel
and that vessel will have a label you
need to identify it that may will be
handwritten and applied at point of
collection
and when these samples come into the lab
you'll have to record them now where
does that go does that go into a lab
notebook
is that manually written down or is
there a better way of managing that data
the rna extraction
you have your protocol on paper now true
you could download this from the website
but how would you
or you have a link to an electronic copy
but how do you integrate this
into your record of what has happened to
this sample
you may want to record the lot numbers
or
the uh information about the kit you're
using
there may be additional information like
certificate of analysis or the
material safety data that you want to
incorporate in your record of what
happened to this this sample so when you
come back you can easily repeat things
or if there's a problem you can look
back and say okay this lot number was
involved in being
this assay and again you have to record
this information using
a lab notebook
you go through the cleanup stand again
we have a protocol
on paper um and again we have lot
numbers of the kit
something you may want to record
especially if it's something where you
want to look back
if there was any kind of anomalies with
your results
so you can troubleshoot back to your
process
again we have the issue of tubes you
need to make sure you have tubes that
are labeled
in an effective way so you can follow
them through the process
and again you're recording everything in
some form of lab notebook
then we have the measurement now it's
likely you have your data
in a spreadsheet how's that spreadsheet
attached to your
to your to your samples process how do
you integrate that into the record of
what you've done
with your sampler each time um
you'll have a digital output from your
spectrophotometer
but ironically often this is then
printed and stuck
into a lab book because there isn't this
uh
a smooth way of integrating that data
directly into
the record of what you've done um again
you have the tutor again we're recording
this
in in the lab
and then the final step in this this
short process and of course we're taking
a snapshot
of what would be a far more complicated
process and just usually
purely five steps is you need to store
it
now when you're storing it you need to
make a record of where you kept it
and that could be on a spreadsheet it
could be in a notebook
we have the tubes again and of course
you'll all know that when you introduce
tubes into a minus 80 freezer often you
get frost filled up
uh it becomes harder to read tubes um
there's a search for freezer space when
you look
if you have a number of freezers unless
you know exactly where you have space to
put
things um often there's a process of
finding out where you can actually fit
something
which actually impacts every sample in
the freezer because when you open the
door
you're letting the the temperature rise
and it has a certain recovery time
and the last thing guard on duty now in
my mind that's a that's the
security guard who's looking after your
freezer facility but actually i like to
expand a little bit more to the freezer
itself
the freezer is what looks after your
work the freeze is an incredibly
important part of this process it's not
just a cold box
it's what protects all the work before
this point
[Music]
how that frieza is performing in this
scenario
is incredibly important how do you know
if there's a challenge with the unit how
do you know how often it's been opened
how can you prove that freedom has been
running within specification
and then can you associate that data
with your sample
so you can come back to the later stage
and be able to say yes i can see
that um my samples kept at this
temperature over this time period
so now let's look at the digital
solutions which
could reduce or remove some of these
challenges the first thing to consider
is an electronic lab notebook
so a central tool to allow you to start
collecting your data
something that allows you to start
organizing data from different sources
and putting it into one record one
auditable
record of what has happened to your
sample
now a lot of lab notebooks can be
cloud-based which means the opportunity
to
well first of all it allows you to
collaborate easily within your working
group
because it's much easier to collaborate
with electronic data
you don't have to be sitting next to
each other to be able to share results
and to gain additional insight
cloud-based solutions of course means
your data is backed up
which is a significant step forward if
you have one lab notebook and it gets
damaged or lost
you've lost that work however an
electronic solution
that can be backed up really does add
another level of security
the other benefit of a digital solution
here is of course
if you have a pile of 10 lab books and
you know somewhere in there is the
insight that you need
to help you with your experiment today
and something you did five years ago
how do you find that usable
records are much easier to search and to
tag
so the first thing and the electronic
notebook sits in most areas
as we look across this this process um
from collection of the samples all the
way through to
recording the data
after you do your rna measurement
it is likely that when you get your
donor information through they didn't
come in some kind of electronic format
now the benefit of basing everything
around an electronic lab notebook is you
can then integrate that file directly
into that
which means the donor paper donate
information on paper
could be could be typed in of course but
if you had a spreadsheet it could be
directly integrated
into the lab notebook
associating all the digital protocols
and documentation becomes
simple when you're using an electronic
documentation system
that can either be attaching the pdf
directly or the documentation directly
it could be just simply including the
link but it means you don't have a
record
based within your lab notebook
and you see where we're addressing
throughout this process
the places where data is brought in or
data is required at the beginning of an
experiment and it's all
associated in the process
now barcaded tubes is it is obvious that
you need
some kind of way of identifying your
tubes
and this could be done by simply writing
it all of us know
the joy of trying to to write your
sample name on the top of an eppendorf
tube
or on the side of an efficient brook
tube um
what you lack here is standardization
if everyone is applying the label and
everyone is handwriting the label
then you don't have a system which is a
easy to read
or b standardized different people's
handwriting
and that information that's included
each time
even where the label is situated could
be different
uh of course barcoding is a big step
forward here so
integrating a barcode at this step
gives you a standardized way of storing
the data so you know the same data is
involved each time and the time involved
with actually
scanning to move it through the process
is hugely reduced
because all of this is done you scan it
in say at this point in time this is
what we did
and that's automatically recorded rather
having to write it all down
the step beyond that is to actually use
pre-barcoded tubes
and the big benefit here of course is
that you don't have to worry about the
variability of applying
a barcoded label yourself or potentially
the variability of where you apply it
also the time implication if you're
working with big data
sets or sorry big sample collection
projects
do you want to be labeling each
individual tube um
pre-barcode tubes often come with
several
versions of the barcode on the tube
which they'll allow you to have
different places
to read the data and faster ways of
reading
for example reading from the bottom but
you can see that
self-labeled cheese this is an important
part in the process
because of course you have to be able to
identify your sample
as it runs through from the patient
collection through the storage
now inventory management is incredibly
important because again
it's focused around the sample saying
where your sample is at any one
moment in time and where it is uh what
what freezer that
it's in or what storage location is
digging in is incredibly important
especially if your project is running
for a number of years
you want to be able to look back and
find samples that you may have collected
last year or if you have a large number
of samples
which specific one do i need but
inventory management doesn't just need
to be samples
it can also be based around reagents and
stocks of
kits which allows you to manage your
inventory
but also allows you to associate that
information directly
with the sample in your process record
it's important here to look at the
inventory management system which
actually directly integrates into
your electronic lab notebook because
that allows you to have
one platform which is managing where
your sample is and what has happened to
your sample at any one time
and you can see this as we go through
we're covering many many elements
of this rna prep um where we're managing
to reduce the risk
or create greater efficiencies
by using digital solutions
so device monitoring and notification
many if you have important
uh samples in a freezer for example you
maybe you already have
a monitoring system something that tells
you if there is a problem
but we could take that a step forward
and start looking at devices
that actually record what is happening
to them at any one moment in time
recording this in a digital way that you
can then integrate
and associate with the sample so you
could say
i can say that this tube
or this sample was in this tube and it
was
pushed into this centrifuge at this
point in time this spec was used and
it was in this freezer and this was the
temperature range it was kept back
i can see the centrifuges within its
service requirements
and as you can see the spec was recently
uh calibrated
with the new generation of smart devices
coming through which allow
the integration of monitoring data into
a cloud-based solution
there's the potential as time moves on
to be able to take all of this data
and be able to create a totally holistic
view
of your sample as it runs through your
laboratory
exactly what's happened to at any one
point in time
and the documentation associated with
that
now what's interesting is what i'm
talking about what could potentially
happen in the future and how the
digitization world
is growing and developing actually many
of these
are available right now of course
electronic notebooks exist
um different ways of
creating or exploring your your digital
protocols and documentation exist
barcelona tubes exist inventory
management platforms
and more and more smart devices are
coming onto the market which allow you
to collect
the data as it happens
from your laboratory and where we will
move
as time goes on is a greater level of
integration
where all of this is pulled into one
single platform
or a small number of platforms which
allow you to build a much more
effective view of your processes what's
happened to your samples
and potentially what
where you can create efficiencies
imagine a situation where your devices
are connected
and actually you can
recognize or it can recognize when it
needs a service
and can proactively tell you or maybe
even practically book a service
visit for you again keeping up time in
your lab reducing your service costs and
reducing risk to you
okay
so hopefully what i've been able to show
you is what you can potentially gain
from the digital world
we've got a reduction in costs
and we have saving time and a reduction
of risk
now i struggle a little bit with pulling
costs and time apart because
the the old saying of time is money is
very true
but it helps me to structure this a
little bit
so when you're looking at reduction in
costs
when you can have a full overview of
your process you can look at process
optimization
you can look at where are we doing
things that we can change what can we
improve
as i mentioned you can look at a
reduction in servicing costs
i mean in in several ways the first way
could be
that um you have a predictive
maintenance
where it actually understands the
challenges uh if the unit is struggling
uh with something that actually needs
some uh some work or it could simply be
that it advises you when something needs
servicing rather than having everything
done at the same time
digital solutions are by their nature
always growing how many people have done
an upgrade on their
mobile phone and found they have new
functionality
and the same is true of most digital
solutions
in the future it's possible that not
only cloud-based solutions where you get
additional functionality regularly but
where you could end up with
new functionality being built into your
physical equipment
equipment that grows with you and where
you can add new
benefits and new functions as time goes
on
or when you decide you need them
as we've discussed there's certainly a
need for remote working and
collaboration
speaking of someone who's not had to go
to their office for three months i've
certainly saved a lot of time with
with travel but you can save time
um by being able to access data
[Music]
easily at home it saves travel time to
the office
and again being able to collaborate
effectively
which is so important that scientific
world is much easier when you're working
within digital platforms
implementing documentation takes time
there is a cost associated with it
however
digital solution almost designed to help
you support documentation
will really reduce that time burden for
you and will allow you to move into a
fully documented process much quicker
you would hope that if you can fully
track what's going on with your sample
and you can standardize your processes
because within your
your laboratory within your lab notebook
you may even have guided
protocols which allow you to see
what you should be doing in each step
where you have your electronic protocol
built in to your workflow not just what
you're recording
but to what you're doing hopefully this
leads to a greater degree of
reproducibility which
saves you time and of course the knock
on is it saves you money
we have data security well as we've
already discussed data security isn't
just an issue for
digital the digital world where you hear
this discuss regularly
is my data say it is your annual data
say
and is it so safe that it's not
searchable making it
kind of unusable so
how safe is your data how usable is your
data
the digital world gives you security
with backups
cutting edge digital security but it
also gives you
usability the ability to search the
ability to archive
and to share data and to control data
having all this data gives you more
process insights process insights of
course
allow you to reduce the risks in the
processes
but again it also can help with process
optimization which will help with
greater reproducibility so these these
three elements really do interact well
together
okay so hopefully i've been able to
highlight
some of the benefits of looking at
moving into a more digital workflow in
your laboratory
what i'd like to do now is to talk about
some of the considerations
that you should think about you've
decided digitization
is where you want to go but how do i
actually implement this within my lab
so clearly the first step is which
solutions
do i want to look at and there are
questions here to ask which is
is this uh software based locally
in my institute is it a cloud-based
software how is the security for the
cloud-based software
is it future-proof is this a solution
that will grow with me and growing my
needs
how can i access this all the normal
questions you'd ask
around a product still exists when
you're looking at a digital solution
is it fit for what i need now and will
this answer my needs in the future
the difference with the digital solution
is how will it grow with my needs
because digital solutions haven't uh
the benefit that they're constantly
developing
right now there's a lot of solutions on
the market and in the future this will
grow there's lots of different elements
that allow you to collect some form of
digital information
so the next question is how well can you
integrate that data together when you're
designing your digital
workflows and you're designing your
digital architecture
for your laboratory how well can i
integrate the data from
this bit of equipment and my samples
and my
process documentation how can i pull
this together
we of course touched on on the sample
when you're looking at the consumables
and again when you're moving into a
digital world it makes
complete sense to look at barcoding um
be that a barcode you apply yourself
or a pre-barcoded tube
when you're looking at a pre-barcoded
tube there's questions to be asked
around how that tube integrates into
your workflow
will you be able to pull additional
information like certificates of
analysis
or potentially just the part number and
specifications of that tube
directly into your process documentation
how easy is that is that a manual
process do you have to
physically download a certificate of
analysis and then associate it
with that sample in your records or is
that an automatic process
how has the supplier of those consumers
made that
process smooth because again
digitization needs to add efficiencies
you need this integration and you need
to look at how you can reduce
the manual steps because any manual step
either will get
lost or potentially
create a point of risk
devices when you start thinking about
devices now
when you look at them are you
considering where that device
will fit into your digital landscape
tomorrow
three years time and five years time the
reality is no one buys a piece of
equipment
and expects it to to be gone in two
years
you're making an investment for a piece
of equipment that should be really for a
significant period of time so are the
products you're investing in now
products that could be integrated into
your digital workflow
in later years right now it may be that
you
don't see digitalization with your
devices as being the next step
and the other places you want to focus
first when you're investing investment
goods and
capital equipment it's important to see
whether or not
they could be integrated at a later
stage and if they can't what other
solutions might be in place to allow you
to pull data from that device
into the
process documentation that you're
creating to really show what's happened
to your sample as it processes through
your laptop
processes now clearly when you're moving
from an analog process
into a digital process there's the
opportunity to look at
what you do in your lab what works what
has happened in the past because that's
the way you've already done it
and how digitalization can allow you to
either remove steps
or to make efficiencies in the physical
work you're doing
not just how you digitally record things
looking at how a process
could be developed
the next topic of infrastructure i think
is quite an interesting one
because digitization still requires you
to have certain things in place before
you get there now
often when you start thinking of
infrastructure you think do we have
enough ethernet ports to connect
equipment
do our scientists have access to tablets
or personal devices
that would allow them to securely access
our data and be able to work effectively
would i need to invest in this
and these are all valid questions of
course
but i would suggest that you need to
look a little bit wider when you
consider infrastructure
which is do we have an i.t department
that can support us
do we have all the stakeholders in place
within the institute or within your
organization
that will support and help you drive
through digitization
because it's not a small change it's
about investment
and it's about changing the way you work
and how you store your data
it is a change and you do need to make
sure that you have the support of all
the major stakeholders within the
process
to actually help you achieve that
people you are changing things
people don't always embrace change so
when it comes to people you need to
think about training
how can we make sure people are
comfortable with the new tools that we
put in place
simply introducing a digital tool
doesn't mean it will be used
and it will work effectively when
introducing new systems you have to go
through some form of change management
which involves telling people why the
change is needed
demonstrating why the change is valuable
and then embedding that change
in your lab culture so digitalization
becomes part of what you do
so this is training it's about making
sure people are comfortable
um it's it's more than just introducing
a tool and expecting it to work
and then potentially the most important
part when you're starting your digital
journey is the support
when you're looking at different
providers of digital solutions
how much support is available and that
may be a commercial supplier
it could be a collaborator within your
institute where you're looking to
develop some form of platform
but what level of support do you have
because if you're trusting your data
and effectively all your work into a
solution
into a digital platform you need to know
that you're going to be supported if
there's a challenge that you can
actually work
to get that data back or be able to get
access to your data if you have
questions someone can help you
because you're investing in a total
system for managing your data
so where do you start well
at eppendorf with the different digital
solutions that we offer we found that
the most
maybe not the most important but the
easiest place to start your digitization
process if you haven't already
is to look at samples now the reason for
this is is that sample
is the most important part it's the
central
uh thread that runs through all your
experiments
be it the physical sample or the data
associated with that sample
that is the most important element of
your of your experiment
so introducing a data
a sample management system allows you to
gain visibility and security around
knowing where your samples are
and the efficiencies based around the
ease of being able to record and check
samples and checks off without a
location so you can always find
samples you can minimize the risk to
other samples through only and closing
the door because you know where the free
space is
but it's also a great entry point into
digitization
because from here it's very easy to make
the next step to an electronic lab
notebook
where you then move from just sample
location to
documenting sample processing and then
the other elements can hang off this
so whenever we're asked about how to
start a digitization process
one of the most easy access points is to
look at
sample management so a sample management
software
something scanning system and tubes
which all integrate together to create a
seamless
sample tracking solution
okay so we we've talked about the
different
challenges and we talked about how
digitalization could potentially solve
some of these problems today
and in the future and we've talked about
some of the considerations
about digitization what you need to
think about when you start to move into
the digital environment
what i wanted to do now is to ask you a
quick question
what do you see as your next step into
digitization so we have a quick poll
that we pushed up
which you guys can quickly answer
where are you next going to look at for
digitization
so the question is are you going to look
at process development what processes
can you change
it could be are you going to look at
inventory management
it could be devices monitoring how can
you integrate a digital
solution there how do you manage your
full experimenting data so an e-lab
a an electronic lab system um
barcode consumables potentially how can
you then integrate that into your sample
management process
um digital lab infrastructure do we have
the infrastructure in place
could be people and training i mean
likely this is later but maybe you want
to start asking people
how they see digitisation fitting into
the lab and of course there is let's
wait and see
so looking at the results it's an
interesting mix um
coming out top is looking at the digital
infrastructure do we have the instructor
in the lab now to actually take that
step forward
people and training and devices and
monitoring are the next
to highest so it's interesting to see
that there's quite a blend across there
um inventory management is also quite
high there are still some of you who
want to wait and see
um although i'm glad to see that is
coming in at the lowest point
okay um if you haven't answered the
screen will drop away
in about 45 seconds so thank you very
much for your interaction it helps you
to have a think about
where you want to go next with
digitisation it also helps us as a
business because we can look at this and
say
okay we now can see where people are
thinking
and we can consider how we can support
you better and how we develop our
products better so thank you very much
for that insight
so
we've been through the pain points and
we've been through the potential
benefits that could solve these issues
and we've looked at the considerations
now all of these things are a journey
and the nice thing about digitization is
most certainly a journey there are
elements you can work at as you go
now eppendorf we offer a range of
solutions so
be it software options which could be
inventory management solutions we have
electronic
lab solutions
it could be smart devices be it a
freezer that can tell
can tell you when someone has opened the
door it can tell you when the doors get
open too long
and stores all that information or a co2
incubator
that can tell you if there's been
fluctuations in the co2 levels
or consumables which are designed to
pull information
directly into a sample tracking software
and populating the additional
information is like ca uh like
snippets of conformity whilst being
the kind of consumer you'd expect from
epidural high quality
high grade plastics designed to protect
your sample the most important thing is
as you go through the digitization
process you look to ways to save time
ways to reduce costs through your
processing and the documentation your
data storage
again looking to reduce risk and all
these things combine
uh to give you peace of mind
and remember this is not just science
fiction this is science now
there are elements of this which can be
done today and as time goes
on we will be able to integrate more and
more functionality
um digitization is is the product that
keeps growing
and it's the solution that will always
keep track with what your needs are
so i really want to say thank you very
much for
for coming um i really hope you found
that useful and there was some insight
that you could take away from that
if you'd like to find out more about how
eppendorf can help you take your first
digital steps
please visit the virtual booth
in the virtual event we're running right
now
the other option is after the
recording is finished we will be
collecting any questions we'll be
sending out
a recording but we'll also have some
links there which will allow you to
interact and find out a little bit more
about
how epidural can support you in your
digital journey
so thanks very much i appreciate your
time and i hope you find the rest of
the digital event useful thank you very
much
and thank you steven for that
informative presentation
and we will now begin the live q a
portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's take a look at the questions
coming already in from our audience
members
stephen how can i ensure
security especially in terms of my
research data
it's a really good question and
in my experience it's one of the first
questions that gets mentioned when you
start talking about a digital solution
um certainly the way eppendorf
approaches it
is that we use a cloud-based system um
and we will use a commercially available
uh
or a commercial provider for example the
microsoft cloud
and the reason for this is they are
experts in security
their job is to keep your data safe um
i think it's interesting is that there's
often a lot of pushback about
the cloud in the professional world but
within the personal world we use it for
our most sensitive data i mean you
wouldn't think twice of logging onto
your bank
what we do have to help people
understand the different steps you put
in place to minimize any risks to your
data
we actually have a white paper which
we'll put a link on to the email
listener afterwards
really discussing how security is is
important
but there are different solutions be it
private clouds
public cloud or potentially for some of
our software packages there's even the
option to have
a local server but then you don't have
the benefits of the cloud solution in
quite the same way
thank you for that and do i have
different options to choose from
in terms of product setup for example
you just mentioned private cloud public
cloud can you talk a little bit more
about that
absolutely sorry
yes absolutely so for our elab
sample management software or our elab
uh electronic lab book there is the
option of either working on a public
cloud solution
um a private cloud solution with
enhanced security
um or potentially if you really must
have your data on site
you can opt to have a local server built
in and it's completely contained within
your own environment
clearly the benefits of a cloud-based
solution is that if there's
updates and there are additional
changes to the software where we add
functionality
that's something that's very easy to do
on a private cloud on a
static install on a server of course we
need to come in and do that all that
needs to be managed by the it department
you don't get that automatic additional
functionality as time goes on
so there are different options depending
on the needs of your business for sure
thank you for that and how easy is it to
connect to smart devices
in the lab like what are the
requirements for that steven
okay so this will depend upon how your
smart devices are set up
so i mean clearly i'm
i know more about the eppendorf solution
so within eppendorf we've
again gone for a cloud-based way of
managing our devices
which means the setup in the lab is
actually very simple all you need is an
ethernet point
which is connected to the internet so
there are some considerations with the
it department to make sure that there's
a port that has access to the internet
but outside of that the process is as
simple as setting up a cloud device
a cloud platform registering your device
on the platform
and then plugging it in and it is as
simple as that
and that will get your devices connected
to our visionize
virtual lab which effectively allows you
to monitor
um from anywhere at any time but it also
allows you to
look at notifications and check back on
the event history
and that can be for one device or a
hundred devices so
certainly from our side it's very simple
there are more challenges of course if
you have
local servers um or it's more of a home
brew solution
but certainly when you look at what
we're proposing for our smart devices
which is actually a very simple process
thank you steven and again audience
members thank you for these great
questions coming in
our next question is which are a
possible
simple option to start barcoded
inventory for consumables
and samples
well i mean the simplest way is is to
to find a piece of software
which allows you to to do sample
management
i mean that's the first step if you're
looking at the easiest way to do it
the easiest way is to find a company
that can provide both
the inventory management software
the scanning solutions and the
consumables
and the reason for that is um and also
potentially the
the cold storage um because what you get
there is a solution that's been designed
to work together
um of course you could always get
barcoding from one company
scanners from another company and your
software from another company that that
that's entirely possible and most
solutions will work
together in some format but if you're
looking to get everything from one place
what that means is that you'll get the
synergies and the benefits
that the manufacturers built in so for
example i know that if you were to use
our barcode solution
our barcode you youtubes when you scan
them in there's a simple
import directly from the scanner
software a one-click button
into our inventory management software
and then the input
management software automatically pulls
additional data about that
tube so the specific analysis the
specifications of the tube
and things like this it pulls it
directly into your
sample record and that happens
automatically
so going for a single supplier really
gives you the benefits of being able to
to to streamline your process so that's
the easiest way
but of course the first step would
always be
consider a sample management program
that gives you ease of use and you get
the support
and does all you need to do that's the
entry point but for a whole section of
course you'll need barcoding and
something a scanning solution as well
thank you and does eppendorf support
the setting up of such tools also the
introduction of such new technology
like um for example expert consult um
consultation absolutely i mean
eppendorf as an organization um i mean
one of our key messages is that we are
an expert partner
i mean anyone that's worked with
eppendorf in the past 75 years will know
that we place huge value on supporting
our customers um
a product isn't just what you buy it's
not a physical box because you buy the
services around that
and eppendorf has always been happy to
work with customers
to try and make sure that our solutions
fit them properly and if you invest with
us
we will try our best to make sure it
works effectively for you
so certainly if you're looking to start
your digital journey we have a number of
experts who'd be happy to
talk about what your needs are and then
when it comes to implementation into the
lab
we can certainly help you with that um
the nice thing is a lot of these
solutions are designed to be
user-friendly they're designed to be
easy to work with however
if you do need help with implementation
absolutely we can support you with that
this is something that is very core to
how epidural have
operated with customers not just today
but
within our long history it's very
important to have that relationship
thank you for that and stephen who do i
have to involve
for getting started in introducing
digital lab solutions in my lab do you
have any recommendations
for that as i touched on earlier there
are a number of different stakeholders
you need to consider
be it the management of the institute
the it department are very important to
involve
which is kind of different from your
normal lab purchase
where you start looking at okay we need
to involve
the it team potentially facilities as
well because you might need the
infrastructure with new ports
put into where you want to site your
equipment
what we do have and what we can
circulate as well
on the email afterwards is um
a white paper on the different people
you need to involve
for both our device management software
solutions our device management
solutions and for our sample and process
management solutions
both of those have got a an introduction
to the kind of steps needed to do your
first
setup and who you need to engage but
realistically you're looking at
facilities
you're looking at key decision makers
maybe even institute directors if you're
looking at a site-wide solution
but most definitely
thank you steven and we have time for a
couple more questions and again thank
you audience member
for your great questions that you've
sent in
are there any trainings or further
webinars available to learn more about
the digital
journey stephen absolutely i mean
there are we have some very direct
salesperson-led presentations which
allow you to
first-hand experience of working with
[Music]
the visionize device management platform
showing you how it works
and what you would expect if you can
invest in smart devices in the lab
within this
[Music]
virtual event there are a number of
experts you can speak to
and we're always pushing out more and
more topics
about distribution our
elab um by weight act sorry who are one
of our
partner companies and are heavily
involved in delivering
um platforms for sample management and
process management
and they have a number of webinars on
their website um
and of course as timely zone we'll be
offering more and more insights
and commentary on digitization
thank you again and we have time for one
more question
is eppendorf offering any services for
monitoring
lab equipment
well this is primarily what visionize is
designed to do
um it's its very first benefit is a
visualized digital lab
platform is designed to
monitor and give you smart notifications
around our smart products which are
currently our premium trees at
premium freezer range the crime cube
f740
hi our top-end co2 incubators
but soon we'll be adding things like our
shakers to it
pcr machines there's a whole range of
products which will be part of this
visionized platform
um where you'll be able to basically
monitor
directly from there and set up smart
user-defined notifications about events
which could be an alarm on a freezer
where it could be simply my runner's
finished on the pcr machine
so the nice thing about digitalization
is it grows
and we're always adding new things into
it
steven i want to thank you again for
your presentation
and as a reminder to our audience those
questions that we were unable to answer
today
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information
you provided at the time of registration
until next time
take care and goodbye
you